bonjour et bienvenue dans les 4 V
Geneviève darrieussec bonjour il y aura
tout à l'heure une conférence sur le
handicap la 6e à l'Élysée sujet au
combien important car privé de fait de
certains droits de certains accès les
personnes handicapées se retrouvent bien
souvent traitées comme des citoyens de
seconde zone dans notre pays sous tous
les gouvernements sous tous les
présidents de toutes les couleurs
politiques de gauche de droite ou
d'ailleurs c'est toujours très bien fait
ce genre de conférence c'est plein de
bonnes intentions qui sont sincères mais
qui trop souvent de se traduisent pas
dans le quotidien des personnes
handicapées moi j'ai une question toute
simple pour commencer est-ce qu'on est
sûr que le palais de l'Élysée est
accessible aux personnes handicapées oui
bien sûr il a été rendu accessible pour
cette conférence nationale du handicap
avec des aménagements simples qui sont
mis en oeuvre chaque fois qu'il y a des
grandes manifestations à l'Elysée mais
ça veut dire que si demain nous édisons
un prison une présidente en fauteuil
roulant il pourra accès à avoir accès au
bureau du président à l'étage ou pas
écoutez je ne suis pas suffisamment
au courant de la géographie parfaite de
l'Elysée des plantes de l'Elysée ce que
je sais c'est que le rez-de-chaussée
sera accessible bon c'est déjà ça c'est
déjà mieux que rien parce que
l'accessibilité c'est la base de tout la
loi du 11 février 2005 ça date pas
d'hier donner 10 ans pour que ce
principe de l'accessibilité pour tous
soit accomplie là on a déjà presque 10
ans de retard sur la date limite le
Conseil de l'Europe a reconnu la
violation des droits des personnes
handicapées par l'état français il
estime que notre pays ne respecte pas
leurs droits fondamentaux est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes d'accord avec
ça est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on a encore
énormément de chemin à faire d'accord
sur le fait que nous avons du retard sur
les sujets d'accessibilité
dès 2014 il y a eu des préconisations
données aux communes en particulier
donner également au privé qui reçoivent
du public les établissements recevant du
public les commerces les restaurants les
cabinets médicaux etc de mettre un
accessibilité
tous leurs espaces publics et tous les
cet environnement recevant du public la
date limite est fin de 1024 pour mettre
un accessibilité et je pense que nous
avons du retard alors il y a eu le covid
mais
ça n'explique pas tout et vous avez
raison les sujets d'accessibilité
en fait sont il n'y a pas que l'État
l'État est responsable de ces
infrastructures mais nous avons aussi
les transporteurs nous avons aussi donc
les privés nous avons également les
communes donc tout un tout un panel de
responsables qui doivent aller vers
l'accessibilité complète pour pouvoir
avancer mieux on va prendre la journée
type on commence par prendre des
transports le matin c'est souvent une
année je le disais tout à l'heure à
Paris on sait que le métro est ancien 3%
de stations qui sont qui sont
accessibles à 500 jours des Jeux
paralympiques ça fait pas beaucoup ce
point des transports au-delà même du
métro parisien de quelle manière allez
vous prendre le taureau par les
qu'est-ce qui va changer qu'est-ce que
vous allez annoncer par exemple nous
avons des gares nationales toutes les
gares nationales doivent être
accessibles il y en a aujourd'hui près
de 170 à peu près la moitié sont
aujourd'hui accessibles totalement alors
accessibles ce sont les quais c'est
l'accès ok mais c'est aussi la
billetterie c'est aussi l'accessibilité
sonore visuelle pour tous les types de
déficits parce qu'il n'y a pas que des
déficits moteurs il y a aussi des
déficits sensitifs et donc l'objectif
pour nous c'est que toutes les gares
nationales soient mises en accessibilité
complète en 2027 et cela sera traduit
dans trois ans il y aura peu 4 ans il y
aura plus de problèmes d'accès dans les
gares en France dans les grandes gares
nulle part ni pour arriver au quai ni
pour monter dans le train ni pour
accéder par ce sera fini ça coûtera
combien écoutez il y a une enveloppe qui
est prévue qui avait été annoncée
d'ailleurs de 400 millions d'euros qui
va être utilisé pour pour cela et je
crois que
en fait l'accessibilité ce n'est pas
utile que pour les personnes en
situation de handicap moteur c'est utile
pour toute la population et une
population avait des seniors les parents
avec des poussettes donc ça rend en fait
la vie plus facile à tout le monde donc
c'est un investissement pour une vie
plus agréable et plus facile autre sujet
problématique c'est l'école alors on a
progressé il y a 430 000 élèves
handicapés scolarisés en 2023 je crois
qu'il y en avait 320 000 en 2017 donc
presque 100 000 de plus aujourd'hui
combien reste sur la touche aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas il y a des enfants qui sont
aussi dans les établissements
médico-sociaux à peu près 100 150 000
mais ne sont pas sur la touche ils sont
aussi scolarisés dans les établissements
médico-sociaux ce qui est la critique
qui est faite c'est que il y a des
scolarités imparfaites c'est-à-dire des
enfants qui n'ont que quelques heures
d'école voire une demi-journée par
semaine pour certains parce que
l'accueil ne peut pas être réalisé dans
les meilleures conditions qui vont
continuer à mettre le paquet sur l'école
parce que pour moi c'est un droit
fondamental les enfants de la République
doivent aller à l'école de la République
quel que soit leurs différences
continuer à travailler pour une école
inclusive qui soit qui prennent mieux en
charge les enfants et ce qu'il manque
aujourd'hui dans l'école il y a bien
entendu les professeurs qui sont formés
il y a les aides les aesh qui entourent
les enfants mais il nous manque très
compliqué pour les parents
parce qu'il nous manque aussi un chaînon
qui devra être un peu plus présent c'est
ce sont tous les professionnels du
médico-social et le médico-social ce
sont des psychomotriciens ce sont des
éducateurs spécialisés ce sont des
ergots thérapeutes ce sont les faire
rentrer dans l'école qui pourront
rentrer dans l'école pour aider la
communauté éducative à prendre en charge
ses enfants et mieux accompagner ses
enfants au quotidien à l'école alors
certains pourront être c'est déjà le cas
dans certaines unités autistes par
exemple il y a des professionnels du
médico-social en permanence dans les
écoles et d'ailleurs ça c'est dans les
établissements spécialisés
dans les écoles maternelles ou primaires
il y a des unités pour accueillir des
enfants autistes ou des professionnels
du médico-social sont présents et
d'ailleurs cela rejaillit un petit peu
leur expérience permet de de
sécuriser un petit peu tout l'écosystème
de l'école pour tous les enfants et je
trouve que c'est une ils vont être
recrutés par l'Éducation nationale ou
par le paraménistère où ils seront ils
viendront en complément de leur activité
sont des équipes dédiées qui pourront
intervenir dans les écoles pour aider
les enseignants et les professionnels
qui sont dans les écoles à accompagner
ses enfants de la meilleure des façons
ils seront combien ça sera partir de
quand on vient nous avons beaucoup de de
d'écoles de collège et de lycée dans
notre pays ce qui est certain c'est que
ces équipes seront déployées
progressivement nous allons commencer
dans certains départements et le
déployer ensuite l'objectif étant qu'en
2027 dans trois ans nous ayons pu
déployer cela dans une majorité de
d'écoles à chaque âge de la vie son
problème quand on est handicapé madame
la ministre la recherche d'un travail
n'est pas le moindre et l'administration
ne fait rien pour leur simplifier la vie
aujourd'hui si une personne travaille
plus qu'un mi-temps elle perd son
allocation adulte handicapé est-ce que
vous trouvez ça juste est-ce que ça va
changer non je trouve pas ça même
ridicule il faut que nous il faut
engager il faut inciter à reprendre le
travail inciter à travailler et vous
savez le travail c'est un objectif pour
les personnes qui vivent avec un
handicap et d'ailleurs nous avons eu
d'excellents résultats ces dernières
années puisque le taux de chômage a
nettement diminué on est passé de 19% à
13% quasiment de la population
dans notre objectif c'est le plein
emploi aussi pour les personnes en
situation de handicapés du travail à
mi-temps est-ce que vous allez revenir
là-dessus
il faut effectivement que nous
favorisions un citron à reprendre le
travail dans de bonnes conditions et on
doit gagner plus d'argent quand on
travaille que quand on ne travaille pas
parce que demain pardon je vous propose
ma question quand on travaille à
mi-temps pourra garder son allocation
adulte handicapé sachant que sont des
gens qui ne roulent pas sur l'or je
pense que oui nous allons président de
la République annoncera cela cet
après-midi je l'espère
pour nous pourrons agir dans ce sens ça
fait partie quand même des évolutions
qui sont je vais dire logique et
évidente qu'il faut porter parmi les
évidences aussi il y a pas de blocs
opératoire adapté au handicap dans tous
les hôpitaux dans tous les CHU de la
ville même pas dans toutes les régions
est-ce que là-dessus il y a un effort
qui va être fait ou pas l'accès à la
santé est une priorité pour le ministre
de la Santé également c'est une priorité
aujourd'hui ce droit à l'accès aux soins
n'est pas parfaitement respectée donc
nous devons multiplier les handyblog
c'est-à-dire des blocs opératoires en
capacité de prendre en charge dans tous
les CHU dans tous les départements dans
toutes les régions c'est quoi d'avoir un
par région et que nous ayons dans chaque
département les capacités à accueillir
des personnes en situation de handicap
beaucoup de handicaps sont de handicap
invisibles
80%. qui nécessite des prises en charge
particulière qui nécessitent des
consultations plus longues qui
nécessitent de les interventions donc il
nécessite des formations des
professionnelles de santé et nous avons
véritablement la volonté d'avancer dans
ce domaine-là 2027 aussi c'est la même
échéance oui c'est les échéances que
nous donnons avec cette conférence
nationale du handicap ce sera 2028 nous
avons nous ferons un plan pluriel sur
cinq ans et je pense que c'est ce
qu'attendent des associations elles ont
raison il nous faut elles seront là les
associations ou pas bien sûr
pas assez de concertation
le collectif handicap il sera là
représente enfin est composé d'une
cinquantaine d'associations dont très
grande partie sera présente cet
après-midi
alors je nous avons travaillé depuis six
mois il y a eu des groupes de travail
500 personnes qui se sont concertées
tout ce qui va être annoncé aujourd'hui
et le fruit de cette concertation qui a
été rigoureuse comme toujours dans le
handicap puisque c'est une des
politiques qui depuis toujours se
construit avec les personnes concernées
et les associations merci beaucoup je
termine aux gens qui a quelques jours la
Défenseur des droits a noté une hausse
de réclamation en matière de lutte
contre les discriminations ce qui a fait
dire à l'ancien des nuits les
producteurs Dominique Farrugia sur
Instagram ceci le handicap reste le
premier motif des discriminations en
France depuis 6 ans on espère que ça
pourra changer merci à vous d'être venu
mal à la ministre et bonne journée au
revoir merci